the republican party is at a crossroads
after saturday's vote to acquit former
president trump
of inciting an insurrection the final
vote was 57 to 43 including
this is this is key seven republican
senators now that was 10 votes short of
the 67 needed for a conviction
in his response the former president
seemed to take his acquittal
as an endorsement but as ed o'keefe
reports from the white house not all
republicans are on his side
top republicans can't agree on what's
next for the gop
we need to unite the party trump plus is
the way back in 2022.
we've got to move on from the cult of
donald trump and return to the basic
principles that the parties always stood
for
the former president's influence on the
party was evident saturday as the senate
voted to acquit him
donald john trump former president
united states
is not guilty as charged in the article
of impeachment
democrats said it wasn't the strength of
the case that left impeachment managers
short
of the 67 votes needed to convict we
didn't need more witnesses
we needed more senators with spines
compared to the first
impeachment trial the 57-43 vote was a
big
shift and the most bipartisan vote to
convict in impeachment trial history
but still only seven republicans joined
all democrats
among them only one alaska's lisa
murkowski
is running for re-election next year and
on saturday the louisiana republican
party's executive committee
censured senator bill cassidy in a
unanimous vote
senate gop leader mitch mcconnell said
he voted to acquit because of his belief
that it was unconstitutional to impeach
any former president but he still blames
trump for sparking the violence at the
capitol last month
there's no question none
that president trump is practically
and morally responsible
for provoking the events of the day
with governors in congressional
elections more than a year away some
party leaders like stephen bolton
head of the chicago gop believe the
rebuilding will begin
well beyond washington the republican
party is going to start to turn more
local
go back to a core republican message
which is
peace in our streets prospering our
homes and liberty in our lives
but that there are still things to learn
from the former president
the populist pulse if you will that he
rode into the white house didn't start
with him it's still
there it was there before he ran for
president and it's still there now and
it will continue to be there
i think the important thing to do is to
concentrate on what president trump
stood for
as far as american policies as and try
to get away from just the man
as we pointed out senator mcconnell
voted to acquit based on constitutional
grounds but over the weekend in his
remarks after the vote
he made clear he thinks the former
president could face criminal charges
for his involvement
in inciting the insurrection noting that
even former presidents are not immune
from prosecution tony he still voted no
on that technicality ed thank you very
much